[Music]
hello everyone thank you very much for
coming to our talk bright and early and
thank you to everyone who's watching
this on YouTube because they had a
little too much fun last night so we're
here to talk to you today about cloud
audit logs and using them to manage your
insider risk about us we're both product
managers on Google cloud my name is
Marie cosgrove Davies and I work on
stackdriver with a focus on logging and
my name is Joseph polenta and I work on
security with a focus on logging and we
work together quite a lot at the
intersection of security and logging
which is audit logs will be showing you
stack drive for today so a little bit of
an intro on stack driver it's a SAS ops
suite from Google used by actives and
operators to monitor and troubleshoot
their applications on GCP on AWS and on
Prem and our mission as stack driver is
to help developers and operators keep
hybrid and multi cloud apps fast and
available stack driver has a number of
components including an APM suite made
up of trace debug and profiler as well
as an error reporting tool what we'll be
focusing on today are the monitoring and
logging portions of the stack driver
platform and will specifically be
talking about audit logs like it says in
the subject of the talk there are three
types of audit logs that we may be
discussing or will be discussing the
first is admin activity audit logs now
these are always on and always free for
the GCP services that produce them and
they tell you about the creation and
deletion of resources the second type of
audit logs is data access audit logs
these logs tell you about data reading
and writing and you must turn them on if
you think about your usage of the cloud
you read and write data a lot more than
you create and delete resources so these
logs may be very high volume and we'll
talk a little bit about how to manage
that volume and the third type of audit
logs is access transparency logs
and these tell you when Google support
or Google engineers access your
resources these logs must also be turned
on and they're available to Platinum and
Gold customers just a little note on
retention admin activity audit logs are
retained for 400 days data access and
access transparency audit logs are
retained for 30 days
and we'll show you how to set up
longer-term storage for your logs as
part of this talk so what are we going
to cover today we know that managing
insider risk requires more than great
logging but you can't manage insider
risk effectively without having a
functional and effective logging
solution so we're gonna help you with
that building block we'll go through the
basics of how to use audit logging we'll
go through some practical tips and more
advanced use cases on using audit
logging on GCP and we'll do it all in
the framework of a case study of a group
that used audit logs to effectively
manage their security on GCP and so
here's our real-world example these are
my cats and they have two hobbies hobby
number one is napping and hobby number
two is being admired and pretty recently
I stopped working from home and I
started working from an office and
suddenly their admiration supply
dwindled because I wasn't looking at
them all day and telling them how cute
they were so they knew they had to go
seek more admiration and these are
pretty business savvy cats they're very
up on new technologies so they decided
to start a cat photos website on GCP as
with any startup each of the cats had a
special role
Halas was the cat executive officer
acorn was the cat and marketing officer
a Nash who's the most tech-savvy of the
three is the cat technology officer now
as the CTO Ashe is the one making most
of the decisions around security and
technology so we'll be following her
today and Joe is going to tell you about
starting on GCP and Ash's exploration of
the admin activity audit logs thanks
very good mo please
Thanks so we're going to jump into our
Google cloud platform console and now
Marie has a lot of confidence in it cats
but they are cats so we just want to
make sure that everything's been set up
properly here so we're in our cat
entrepreneurs project which is the
project that the cats created to run
their website on GCP we're going to jump
into our logging console here in stock
driver logging now admin activity audit
logs are on by default for all services
that produce them what does this mean it
means that if you create or delete a
resource for example a GCS bucket will
automatically create a log of that for
you and store it for free for 400 days
those logs can't be deleted so if
someone inside your company is trying to
cover up something that happened at work
by deleting the log that won't be
possible so let's go ahead and select
the GCS bucket and we'll go ahead and
select the admin activity logs for that
bucket I'm going to go ahead and select
all of the admin activity logs going
back over time now what I can see here
this is how you know it's real is that
like it's taking a little bit to life
what I can see here is that I've got a
list of all of the creates and deletes
that happen to my resources on GCP I can
see who did them I can dive in here and
expand these all to see a little bit
more information now I want to stress
that while you do get the admin activity
logs for write activity things that
creates deletes updates you don't
actually get admin activity logs for
reads in respect of your admin metadata
what that means is if someone goes ahead
and reads the access control list on a
GCS bucket you won't automatically get
an admin activity log of that you'll
need to turn those on separately and
we'll cover how to do that in the second
section of this talk but what you will
get is if someone deletes a bucket you
automatically get the log of that and
you don't need to turn those on and as
you can see here we get a bunch of
information that's useful for auditing
what happened in this particular active
action so I can say that it was Murray
who did the activity there's an audit
log created
and you know she had permission granted
from this commission and this was the
action that she did and the IP that she
did it from so that's admin activity
audit logs and now we'll cut back to
Murray who's going to talk a little bit
more before we go into detail and have a
concern on other types of logs all right
so it turned out that cat photos on the
internet were a hugely underserved
market
the cats are business geniuses and so
they need to scale their business they
have to hire and they look around and
they find this a great engineer his name
is Sherlock you can see him right here
he has a lot of experience in cloud but
he's new to GCP so he's learning and
what ash realized is that as they're
scaling the business this is the right
time to make sure they have all of their
security set up so that they're logging
everything they need they have their
long-term log storage set up just to
make sure that in case of anything
anything happening they were prepared to
deal with it and Joe is going to show
you how that happens awesome thanks Mary
so in this section we're gonna talk a
little bit about enabling data access
and admin read order logs and exports
can we go I'm gonna jump back to the
demo so I'm back in my Google Cloud
console on my home page if a head to the
navigation menu and I scroll down to the
I am in admin section I can see that
there's an option to select audit logs
if I jump in here I'm gonna zoom out a
little bit because of the resolution on
this screen hopefully you can also see
that yes great
so what can I see here these are all the
services that I've enabled on Google
cloud platform so I'm using sort of
cloud datastore API as an example or I'm
using cloud key management service now I
can scroll through this list and I can
see all of the services that I have
enabled and I can individually configure
my audit logging for each one so I'm
gonna go ahead and select this cloud
composer API and I'm gonna go ahead and
turn on those admin read audit logs that
I was talking about before so those are
going to give me the read activity of
the administrative related metadata on
this service so if someone read an
access control list
I'll now get an order log of that what
about data reads and data writes I can
go ahead and turn those on too so these
will now generate audit logs whenever
someone accesses or writes data to the
resources that are inside the service so
to use Google Cloud Storage as an
example again I would now get an get an
audit log every time someone reads or
writes to us to a bucket on GCS and now
you remember that we said that these
might be pretty high volume logs so Joe
is gonna show you how to mitigate that a
little bit yeah
so you're probably thinking at this
point reading and writing from a storage
bucket on GCS or from a database is
going to generate a ton of blogs I mean
a lot of you would run production
systems that face millions of users and
every time each one of those users does
an action it's probably going to read
from maybe one if not more data stores
on GCP and so as you can imagine the
logs pile up very very quickly
and so what you may want to do is use
the exempted users functionality to stop
automated accesses to that data so this
is usually things like service accounts
or other accounts that on a regular
basis talk to other other services at a
low level inside GCP one example is you
may have a production front-end that has
a service account that talks to a
database on the backend and is regularly
pulling data out of there and generating
a ton of data access order logs you may
not be as interested in this activity
because it's not a human actor so it's
not someone from inside your company
who's going and changing and deleting
resources it's just the sort of
functioning of your app in general and
you may prefer to have like other
analytics in place that sort of less
heavy duty that collect the information
to do with this stuff so what you can do
here is you can click this add exempted
user button and you can insert the name
of whether it's a person or a service
account into this box and you can you
can exempt them from certain log types
I'm not going to go ahead and enable
this just now but what I will say is
that you should be careful when you use
this feature and the
reason is that if you add an exempted
user to this box they won't generate
audit logs and so you need to make sure
that you have appropriate security
controls in respect of that user for
example you have a service account you
know that it generates a lot of audit
logs and so you say I'll add it to the
exempted users list you add it to the
exempted users list but all the people
who work for your company have access to
that service account and can grab the
credentials for an SSH into it and do
whatever they want so now what you've
done is you've created a situation where
lots of people can go ahead and do
things with service account that won't
be logged so we have a couple of other
talks on securing service accounts you
can look up on YouTube what happened
yesterday and you can find out more
about how we've got security features in
place that help you secure those
accounts and we've just released
recently a GCP next a new feature called
binary authorization that also helps
around securing service accounts but
I'll let you guys look that up in your
own spare time so I want to click on
this button here that says default audit
config as well I want to talk a little
bit about this you're probably thinking
there's a huge list of services here
what happens if you know I can figure
this on Monday and then on Tuesday
someone goes and starts using a bunch of
new other services that I didn't
configure or looking for do I have to
just keep going back and configuring
configuring new audit logs for those
services and for that we've created this
feature called the default audit config
so you can click on this button at the
top it's going to send you to this page
this essentially allows you to configure
audit logging for all the services so
even when a person starts using a
service you've never configured before
you can just select this default audit
config save it and then that service
will automatically have those logs
enabled when it's when people start
using it so you can see here there's a
tooltip that says these logs are enabled
as part of the default order confi so
that's that's a useful feature as well
the last thing I want to touch on that I
won't demonstrate is organization level
audit logging so the configurations for
audit logging obey the
inheritance of I am system so if you
create an audit log in config at an
organization level and you say
everything in my organization log
everything for every service that will
be inherited down by the projects and so
you'll see a tick here that says these
logs been enabled as part of the
organization level confi so that's
available to you as well
you'll need to do that using our API so
you'll need to pull down the a.m. config
for the organization and enable it there
so that is how we enable data access and
admin read audit logs on DCP and now I'm
going to jump to stack travel logging in
and show you a little bit about what we
can do with those so one other thing ash
wanted to make sure she set up was
exports because as we mentioned your
admin activity logs are retained for 400
days but your other audit logs are
retained for 30 days so if you want to
keep them or you need to keep them for
compliance reasons you can export them
to GCS for long term storage or to
bigquery if you want to keep track of
them and so Joe is going to show us how
that happens great so I'm back in stack
travel logging and I can see now I've
selected this data access type of audit
logs and I can see all the data access
or operations that are happening in
respect to this in respect this bucket
so there's a bunch of list operations
those are when someone says fetch me a
list of all the files that are in this
bucket you'll get an audit log of the
list operation and I can see that
they've been different people who have
been doing that at my company so as
Marie said we're only going to hold on
to these order logs for 30 days you're
going to want to do a whole lot of
things these audit logs you're going to
want to use them in other tools that you
have set up and other processes inside
your business you're going to want to
export them because you want to store
them for longer than 30 days in some
weather it's a bit cheaper so we've got
this export feature inside statue have a
logging that allows us to do that you
can just hit this create export button
at the top
and it will export whatever you have in
this in this filter here so right now
I'm exporting all the GCS bucket logs
that are of the data access type but I'm
actually I'm actually going to want to
export all of my GCS bucket logs so I'll
change the filter and my export will now
work off this new filter so in order to
do this we need to create what's called
a sink so this sink is like the point of
integration with such a volume so I'm
just gonna call it sink not a very
creative person so I'm going to export
into a service and we support three
different exports the first one is
bigquery why would you want to use
bigquery to analyze your logs so as you
can see here in stackdriver logging
we've got a pretty robust user interface
that you can use to analyze the logs we
showed before about how you can click
through you can do sort of searches and
filters up here at the top what bigquery
becomes useful is if you want to join
multiple data sources together so you
may have a data source that has the I
don't know the organizational chart for
example of the people at your company or
you may have a data source that has that
has a list of sort of metadata fields
for each of the data sources at your
company that specifies like what is sort
of high sensitivity versus low
sensitivity whatever that may be you may
have these different data sources and
you want to draw them all together and
you want to run a query that says show
me everything that people who work in my
reliability engineering team who have
access to the user data inside my
company have done in the last 30 days
you can run that sort of query and
bigquery very very easily so that's why
you might want to export your logs in to
be crew
cloud storage so this is a second type
of export that we can set up cloud
storage is very useful for storing logs
for a long period of time for archival
purposes so once we have this thing set
up it's going to start drawing all the
audit logs out of our stock travelogue
and console and into cloud storage as a
copy as Murray said the data access
audit logs are only stored for 30 days
whereas once they're in cloud storage
they just sit there and you just pay the
cloud storage rates which are very very
cheap for storing this kind of data so
once you have them in cloud storage
we're gonna touch a little bit later on
some security features you can enable
there to make sure that people can't
just go in and delete the logs very
easily but you can essentially set them
there and it's one less thing you need
to worry about you'll have all of your
logs backed up to a cheap location and
then if hopefully this doesn't happen
but if an incident happens down the
track and you discover that something
happened two months ago or 10 months ago
or a year ago you can just go hit that
cloud storage bucket pull up the copy of
your logs and perform any forensics that
you need - one thing that a lot of
people do is they may store it in the
cloud storage bucket and then you know
if you need to do advanced advanced
analysis of these logs grab them from
stack or from cloud storage throw them
into bigquery
and then do the analysis you need to do
that and then finally we've got cloud
pub/sub cloud pub/sub is really useful
if you have a tool that you might use
regularly like a sim tool or similar
that you have on site and it's
collecting let's say all the logs from
your on-premise environment all the logs
from your other cloud services and the
logs from uucp
that you might be using and you just
want to pipe your audit logs directly
into that tool because you don't want to
have to set up a new process you just
want to sort of bolt it onto your
existing process that's where cloud
pub/sub is super useful so you create a
cloud pub/sub sync we grab a topic
and you can subscribe to that topic from
your from your other tool and every time
a new event is created it will just pull
it into that new tool and you don't have
to worry about it
so that's exports and there are fairly
useful and powerful feature that we
support inside inside stackdriver
logging we'll talk a little bit more
about them later on in the deck but I
will just hand it back to marina so we
can talk a little bit about some stuff
alright so now as many of you know
you're on call and ash is also on call
as this one of the two engineers
currently on the team and one day a page
woke her up from a nap the photos on the
cat website weren't rendering and that's
their their main business so it's a
pretty big problem and so she went to
the GCP console to investigate now ash
knows that naming is one of the hardest
things in software and she solved the
problem so all of the photos are in a
google cloud storage bucket that's
called very important bucket not can we
go back to the demo please thank you
highly secure name highly secure so if
we go into Google Cloud storage her
first step is going to be looking to see
if the buckets there and it looks like
it's not now if she didn't know about
audit logs she wouldn't really be able
to troubleshoot but since she does and
she's now very well-versed in audit logs
she's going to go into logging and she's
going to take a look at these GCS bucket
audit logs and we're specifically
concerned with the admin activity audit
looks because that's where a deletion
would show up so it looks like there was
a delete operation on our very important
bucket by Sherlock who's still learning
how to use GCS so you must have
accidentally deleted the most important
bucket for the cats and now since
there's no alerting setups to their chat
channel or email alerts setup he didn't
realize it was a problem ash got paged
so there are a couple things that ash is
gonna want to do first she may want to
set up an alert to let her know via chat
or via email or even a page if this
bucket is removed again and second she
might want to see if there's anything
else that Sherlock might have done
accidentally because he's still learning
the platform so let's do that second one
first and if we click on this we'll be
able to show matching entries and you'll
see that our search field has expanded
from a single line to our more advanced
search what we really want to look for
here is we'll remove the GCSE bucket
because we want to look at all of the
activity that Sherlock has been doing
and a lot of creation and deletion but
also this one set I am policy which is a
little suspicious so we can go down and
see who Sherlock has been giving access
to let's see he gave cloud functions
access and data proc access all this
access to whom oh my gosh too sneaky
spike added gmail.com he must have been
fished he's still learning because ok
but this is something else that ash
might want to set up and alert for so if
we want to set up for instance an alert
for deleting our very important bucket
we're gonna do the same show matching
entries so we're searching for delete
searching for very important bucket
we're going to remove Sherlock because
anyone might delete this bucket and so
now we've got our log as we have our
filter set up and what we're going to do
is create a metric that will allow us to
alert on this problem through
stackdriver monitoring and gosh lots of
people have been deleting this bucket
who would do that ok so we will call
this very important bucket actions I
will actually make it a new one and
we'll go ahead and create that metric so
now if we go over to our stack driver
monitoring we can go into alerting and
we can create a policy based on this
metric that we just defined so we'll add
our condition we want a metric threshold
so we'll select that and because I work
on stack driver I know that these
metrics are going to be called logging
slash users so all of what our call
log based metrics in stackdriver will
show up in stackdriver monitoring as
logging slash user and then the name of
the policy or the the metric excuse me
so we're looking for a very important
bucket deletion and what we want to do
is alert if this is above zero now
there's no data available for the
selected time frame because I just
created this metric and no one's deleted
the bucket since so that's good so I'll
go ahead and save this I will add an
email notification to cat technology
officer at gmail.com which shockingly
was available when I added it for this
demo and then we'll name it it's gone
alright and so now I'm not gonna go
ahead and create and delete the bucket
but if I did this is what my alert would
look like in Ash's email so it'll tell
me what happened and they'll give me a
link to the cloud console to go
investigate okay uh so now ash is
starting to set up a lot of different
alerts on various security things and
what she quickly realized is that all of
these alerts are really digging into her
napping time remember the cats two
favorite things are napping and being
admired and this website is covering the
admiration but like napping is tricky
now so what the cats really need to do
is to automate their security they have
to start seeing what the common problems
are and how they're consistently solving
them and then writing some automation to
handle those so they can stick to
napping and so this is what ash did and
this is a simple example of how to
automate some of your security using
cloud functions so Joe told us a little
bit about setting up sinks and in this
case ash has noticed that everyone's
supposed to apply a label to all of
their products when they spin them up
but that's a really hard thing to
remember how to do so she wants to
automate it so she can stop going back
and adding them post emptily
so the first thing is to go to the logs
browser and she's going to define a
filter and actually I've already I've
got a pre-baked cake in the oven that is
an export so I will just show you the
filter we've already defined and what
this is going to do is it's going to
tell us about when we have a new VM in
compute engine so it is an admin
activity long that's what the top line
is and we're inserting a compute engine
instance and anything goes here and
we've called this audit log new instance
and it's a cloud pub/sub topic and so
every time we create a new VM in clouds
clouds GCE excuse me will get a message
to the pub sub topic and we will trigger
our cloud function so if we go over to
cloud functions we've got this this
function called add label to new VMs and
it's looking at the audit log new
instance topic and if we take a look at
it nothing has happened lately but we
can see the trigger type is cloud
pub/sub the topic is audit log new
instance and you can't view the source
but I swear this will add the label end
of prod to a new VM and so let's go take
a look at that and see if it works we
copy the source directly from stack
overflow didn't we so we'll create a new
instance it will be called instance
seven because again we are very good at
naming we'll make it super tiny and
create so if I take a look at this
instance right now then I would expect
it to have no labels if I can load it
welcome to live demos there we go
oh it already applied anyway if I had
managed to open it before my very quick
cloud function applied we would have
seen labels none but now the cloud
function has kicked in it's applied this
end fraud label and the cats have
managed to automate away this task that
was taking them ten minutes of napping
time of day so that's a lot more napping
all told and this is just a very simple
example of a really powerful and complex
capability that you have with audit logs
which is you can automate all sorts of
challenges or security or unroofed non
security related can we go back to the
deck please so what else might you want
to automate using these well so you
might want to automate something like
checking to see if new users are part of
your org and removing their ability to
do anything if they're not you might
want to automate adding firewall rules
to new VMs this is a super powerful tool
that you have available so now that the
cats have automated their security
they're able to nap they're able to be
admired and they know their site's
secure so it's a really happy ending
which I don't know how many of you work
in security but these are really rare in
the security space so everything is
great and that Joe is going to tell you
a little more thanks Mary so everyone
loves napping everyone loves getting
admiration in order to do that obviously
we need to keep powering up our security
practices to free up our time to allow
us to do that so today we've covered
audit logs we've covered how important
they are as part of your security
strategy one thing we have had a few of
is sometimes we get a frantic call from
a customer saying help something's
happened and I don't have data access
audit logs on can you is there any way
you can recover the data access audit
logs that would have been generated you
know 60 days ago and unfortunately the
answer is no so the audit logs get
generated when you
and so you need to make sure that you
have these on in advance it is a little
bit of work as we as we set saw before
it takes a few minutes but the
investment is well worth it you get them
set up ahead of time you have a process
where you're storing them and archiving
them and it's a really great insurance
policy in the case that something does
happen and you just need that extra
information the other one is having
teams and processes in place so helps to
have great tooling it helps have people
who are trained to use it and if you
don't already have that in place you
should get that set up
auditing things on a regular basis and
clearing through them with an
established process is a lot easier than
going back later on and trying to set it
all up at once when you've realized that
something is amiss and finally maturing
only once you've automated so you don't
want to go ahead and start automating
everything well ahead of time because
you think it's going to be a problem see
how you go first see what you're doing
repetitively and then invest the time
into automating that so we also wanted
to talk a little bit a little bit about
compliance with audit logging as well
obviously using audit logs for security
reasons is a big use case but you may
have a compliance standard or your own
internal policies that you need to
comply with as well so what can you do
to make compliance super easy using
audit logs
the first one is using aggregated
exports and we'll dive into exactly how
this works later but aggregated exports
allow you to export all the audit logs
for all your projects in your
organization into a bucket and that's
going to be really useful if you need to
archive them for a long period of time
like we said before GCS is very cheap
great way to archive your logs and
they've just announced a new bucket lock
feature that can give you some
additional security over to make it to
make sure the logs are even more tamper
proof than they were before you should
obviously have them in a GCS bucket that
it that has a really strict security
policy on it you don't want to have it
so that anyone can access the bucket but
the bucket lock feature gives you
additional sort of security features
that allow you to lock it down even
further you can read more about that on
the GCSE documentation so aggregated
export
what are these and why would we want to
do them so an aggregated export is where
you export all the logs for all the
projects in your organization new
projects get automatically included you
there's a there's a command here we
won't run this because if we run it
it'll do an aggregated export of every
single project at Google and that'll
just set the data center on fire so what
you can do is you can run the your own
version of this aggregated export on
your own on your own GCP organization we
do have really detailed docs on
aggregated exports and how they work so
if you search for aggregated exports
Google stackdriver you'll turn those up
this is a really common request we get
from users is how do I make sure that
new projects are covered in my audit log
exports and so we wanted to make sure we
covered it yeah so head to your favorite
search engine I'm not gonna suggest
which one but type in aggregated export
stackdriver logging and there's a full
guard and how you can set it up the
query we have here is just an example so
obviously it's not going to work on your
own project but it's just a g-cloud
command that you can use from the sdk
that'll set up the stackdriver automated
aggregated exports for this org and
you'll get it all into into a bucket the
last thing we wanted to touch on was
access transparency logs so we did touch
on these a little bit at the start these
are these logs that you're going to get
if support access your information for
whatever reason these are only available
on GCP they're only available to
Platinum and Gold customers and they
give you basically visibility all the
way down the stack to like even things
that engineering are doing so it just
gives you again plugging that sort of
last frontier of gaps that exists over
on the cloud provider side audit logs
are great for covering things that
happen inside your own org but if
someone calls up support and says to
support hey I'd like help because I
can't access what's in this bucket this
will make sure that if support read the
access control list on that bucket you
get an order log of that so let's just
dive into this a good example access
transparency log here I'm going to just
zoom in to each of these bits so we can
sort of talk through what's inside each
of them so at the top you obviously get
the type you can you can see it's an
actor an access transparency log you get
a little bit of information about the
person making access you can see it was
a person who was he's usually located in
Canada but right now they're in the US
and they work for Google LLC you get
some information about what happened
so here someone read the access control
list on the bucket
whoever's have cooling that stopped
support from sort of reading what's in
the bucket but even if they read
something as small it's like a label on
a VM or the name of a VM or the access
control list on a bucket you will get a
log of all of that stuff and then
finally the reason why that happened so
you can see here that you open up a
support ticket
case number bar one two three you can go
ahead and grab that support ticket read
everything that happened in it and think
yep this is kind of what I would expect
I needed to I was having access trouble
accessing what was in the bucket and the
support tech when I checked the access
control list to see if I had appropriate
permissions so these are useful you can
grab them they work exactly the same as
all the other logs and stack travel
logging so all the things we've just
covered today around setting up alerts
setting up monitoring those are all
covered you can use this as part of an
automation suite with Google Cloud
functions highly encourage you if you
have platinum or gold support to get
these set up and you can start using
them today so if you want to learn more
about audit logs just Google GCP cloud
audit logging super easy way to find all
of our documentation I've got some
pretty extensive documentation there and
we have some other webinars that are on
the web as well that you can watch or
you can catch up on this talk if you're
not already awesome thanks everyone
[Applause]
[Music]